WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE MASS
SHOOTING HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
INVEST
INVESTIGATORS SAY THE GUNMAN
SHOT AND KILLED HIMSELF IN THIS
CARGO VAN YOU'RE LOOKING AT,
WHEN CAUGHT UP WITH HIM HOURS
AFTER THE RAMPAGE.
POLICE IDENTIFIED HIM AS
74-YEAR-OLD HUU CAN TRAN.
WE'RE TOLD HE WENT TO A SECOND
DANCE HALL IN A NEARBY CITY,
ALHAMBRA WHERE BYSTANDERS TOOK
HIS GUN.
THE GUN IS A SEMIAUTOMATIC
MISSAL THAT ARE ILLEGAL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SUSPECT WAS A REGULAR AT THE
DANCE STUDIO WHERE THE ATTACK
TOOK PLACE.
THIS IS A VERY DISTURBING STORY.
NO RIMHYME OR REASON, THREE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
>> VERY DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS THE FIRST LUNAR NEW YEAR
CELEBRATION, THE FESTIVAL FOR
THE CITY, THE FIRST ONE SINCE
COVID.
A CHANCE FOR THIS COMMUNITY TO
RECONNECT AND REENGAGE AFTER ALL
OF THIS ANTI-ASIAN RACISM ONLY
TO HAVE ONE OF THEIR OWN COMMIT
THIS HEINOUS CRIME.
>> WHAT I WANT TO DO HERE IS TO
SAY TO THE COMMUNITY, FEEL SAFE.
YOU ARE NO LONGER IN DANGER.
>> THE MONTEREY PARK SHOOTING
SUSPECT IS DEAD FROM A
SELF-INFLICTED GUN SHOT WOUND.
LAW ENFORCEMENT TRACKED A WHITE
CAR GO VAN THAT FIT THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE VEHICLE OF
INTEREST.
FOR HOURS S.W.A.T. OFFICERS
TRIED TO GET THE SUSPECT TO
SURRENDER.
>> HOMICIDE DETECTIVES ARE,
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK
GATHERING ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
AND WORKING ON DETERMINING THE
MOTIVE BEHIND THIS EXTREMELY
TRAGIC EVENT.
>> LAW ENFORCEMENT SOURCES TELL
CNN THE SUSPECT MAY HAVE CAUGHT
MEDICAL TREATMENT SHORTLY BEFORE
THE STANDOFF.
>> IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS TERRIBLE.
>> TO SEE THIS HAPPEN IN THIS
PLACE IS SHATTERING.
>> Reporter: THE 72-YEAR-OLD
ALLEGED SHOOTER OPENED FIRE AT A
DANCE STUDIO WHERE THE CITY'S
LARGE ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
WAS CELEBRATING THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR'S SATURDAY NIGHT.
THE GUNMAN THEN LEFT THE SCENE
AND TARGETED ANOTHER NEIGHBORING
DANCE STUDIO WITH A
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPON BUT IT WAS
WRESTLED FROM HIM.
>> THE SUSPECT WENT TO THE
ALHAMBRA LOCATION AFTER HE
CONDUCTED THE SHOOTING AND HE
WAS DISARMED BY TWO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO I CONSIDER TO BE
HEROES, BECAUSE THEY SAVED
LIVES.
>> Reporter: THE ALLEGED SHOOTER
IS ASIAN AMERICAN AND BELIEVED
TO HAVE ACTED ALONE.
A REGULAR PATRON OF THE STAR
BALLROOM DANCE STUDIO, EVEN
MEETING HIS EX-WIFE THERE.
>> WE WILL GET OVER THIS CRISIS
BECAUSE WE MUST.
AND WE WILL ONLY DO SO IF WE DO
IT TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY.
>> Reporter: TEN PEOPLE WERE
PRONOUNCED DEAD AT THE SCENE,
MAKING THIS MASS SHOOTING THE
DEADLIEST SINCE THE UVALDE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SHOOTING LAST
MAY.
THE SHERIFF DESCRIBED MANY OF
THE VICTIMS AS BEING IN THEIR
50s, 60s OR OLDER.
>> GUN VIOLENCE NEEDS TO STOP,
AND I HOPE THAT THIS TRAGEDY
DOESN'T GO ON A LIST OF MANY
OTHERS THAT WE DON'T EVEN TALK
ABOUT UNTIL THE NEXT ONE COMES
UP.
>> WE ARE GETTING A STUNNING
EYEWITNESS VIEW FROM THAT SECOND
DANCE STUDIO, THE ONE IN
ALHAMBRA, JUST NEAR THIS
MONTEREY PARK LOCATION.
BRANSON SAY, TELLS "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," QUOTE, HE WAS LOOKING AT
ME AND LOOKING AROUND, NOT
HIDING THAT HE WAS TRYING TO DO
HARM.
HIS EYES WERE MENACING FROM HIS
BODY LANGUAGE, HIS FACIAL
EXPRESSION, HIS EYES.
HE WAS LOOKING FOR PEOPLE.
AND THAT GUN, DONE IS WHAT GOT
POLICE TRACKING -- UNRAVELING
THIS ENTIRE CASE.
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE THEY
SAY THE GUN IS WHAT GOT IT
UNRAVELING IT.
BUT THEY'RE SAYING THE GUN WAS
ILLEGAL HERE IN CALIFORNIA, BUT
I WONDER IF IT WAS MODIFIED AND
HOW THEY WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
HIM THROUGH THE GUN IF IT WAS
ILLEGAL.
I WANT TO BRING IN RETIRED LAPD
SERGEANT, CHERYL DORSEY.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE TO
THIS.
MAKE SENSE OF THIS.
IS THERE ANY WAY TO MAKE SENSE
OF THREE DIFFERENT LOCATIONS?
WAS THERE ANGER?
WAS THERE HATE?
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE BECAUSE HE
IS AN ASIAN AMERICAN.
>> MY GUT TELLS ME HE HAD BEEF
WITH THAT PARTICULAR COMMUNITY.
WE UNDERSTAND ALL THE VICTIMS
WERE BASICALLY HIS
CONTEMPORARIES, PEOPLE IN THEIR
50s, 60s, 70s.
BEFORE I KNEW HE WAS A FREQUENT
VISITOR AT THE PARTICULAR DANCE
HALL, HE HAD A RELATIONSHIP, HIS
EX-WIFE, HAVING MET HIM THERE, I
KNEW THERE WAS SOMETHING
PERSONAL ABOUT THOSE TWO
LOCATIONS HE WENT TO MONTEREY
PARK FIRST, DID WHAT HE DID
THERE, AND TRIED TO DUPLICATE
THAT IN ALHAMBRA, BUT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO TOOK THE GUN AWAY
FROM HIM, PREVENTED ANOTHER
TRAGEDY FROM OCCURRING THERE.
WE HAVE TO FIND OUT THE WHY.
THAT'S THE THING EVERYONE WANTS
TO KNOW, WHY HE ACTED OUT THE
WAY HE DID.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE WEAPON,
A SEMIAUTOMATIC PISTOL, THE
SHERIFF, RICHARD LUNA, SAYING IT
WAS ILLEGAL HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
CAN YOU HELP US PUT IT TOGETHER.
>> IF IT'S AN ILLEGAL GUN, THAT
MAKES ME THINK HE POSSESSED IT
ILLEGALLY, OBTAIN IT ILLEGALLY.
THEN THERE WOULDN'T BE A REAL
REGISTERED OWNER WE COULD TRACK
AS IF THE GUN HAD BEEN PURCHASED
LEGALLY.
SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW THEY
WERE ABLE TO RECONCILE THE TWO.
>> EVERYTHING IS CLOSE TOGETHER.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE THE POLICE
STATION, CITY HALL IS, WE'RE
STANDING IN FRONT OF THE STAR
DANCE STUDIO HERE IN MONTEREY
PARK.
POLICE WERE HERE WITHIN THREE
MINUTES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THEIR
RESPONSE?
>> OBVIOUSLY, L.A. COUNTY
SHERIFF IS A LARGE AGENCY.
OFFICERS ARE TRAINED, AND WE SAW
SAW WHEN THE S.W.A.T.S  OFFICER
ENGAGED THE SUSPECT IN TORRANCE.
THE OFFICERS WERE ABLE TO
ASCERTAIN WHAT THEY NEEDED IN
TERMS OF IDENTIFYING THE VEHICLE
THAT THE PERSON WAS IN, GETTING
PICTURES AND PUTTING THAT OUT
THERE SO THAT EVERYONE WITHIN
SOUTHERN LOS ANGELES COULD BE ON
THE LOOKOUT FOR THIS VAN AND
SUSPECT.
>> THEY WERE ABLE TO APPREHEND
HIM, LESS THAN 24 HOURS.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME AS WELL
THAT THE L.A. COUNTY SHERIFF,
THE LUNAR PARK OFFICER SAID
THESE WERE YOUNG OFFICERS.
>> MOST OF THE SHERIFFS START
OFF IN THE JAILS.
YOU START OFF WORKING AS A
DETENTION OFFICER, IN THE JAIL,
THEN AFTER SO MANY YEARS YOU GET
YOUR STRIPES AND YOU COME TO THE
STREETS AND WORK PATROL.
SO IT'S NOT UNCOMMON TO
ENCOUNTER A DEPUTY WHO DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF STREET EXPERIENCE
BUT YET THE OFFICERS WERE
CLEARLY WELL TRAINED AND RELIED
ON THE TRAINING AND KNEW WHAT TO
DO IN THIS INSTANCE, THEY DIDN'T
HESITATE FOR A MOMENT AND SAVE
LIVES.
>> ONE OF THE WORDS HE USED WAS
THEY WERE NOT PREPARED FOR THE
CARNAGE THEY SAW AND THAT WAS
EXTE
EXTENSIVE.
>> HOW CAN YOU?
EVEN A VETERAN OFFICER WOULD
HAVE BEEN SHAKEN TO THEIR CORE
TO SEE THE DEATH AND DESTRUCTION
THAT WENT ON IN THAT DANCE HALL.
SO THE FACT THAT THESE OFFICERS
WERE YOUNG ON THE JOB CERTAINLY
DOESN'T SPEAK TO THEIR
INEXP
INEXPERIENCE, YOU KNOW, THEY
KNEW WHAT TO DO, THEY WERE WELL
TRAINED AND ACTED ON THAT.
>> IT SPEAKS TO THE TRAUMA THE
COMMUNITY IS FEELING HERE, AND
POLICE ARE VICTIMIZED AS WELL BY
THIS.
YOU'RE PART OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY, A PERSONAL
STORY BECAUSE YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE STORY, YOUR MOTHER WAS
PREPARED TO GO TO SOME OF THESE
LUNAR NEW YEAR CELEBRATIONS.
>> WE WERE HERE THIS WEEKEND,
SATURDAY, THE DAY BEFORE THE
SHOOTING.
MY MOTHER LIVES 5, 10 MINUTES
FROM MONTEREY PARK, THESE ARE
THE RESTAURANTS, MY GROCERY
STORE IS HERE, THE COSTCO HAS
ASIAN AMERICAN ITEMS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
HERE IN MONTEREY PARK, IT IS AS
IF THE ENTIRE ASIAN COMMUNITY IS
CONNECTED AND MOVING TOGETHER.
YOU CAN EAT IN ONE BLOCK A
CHINESE MEAL, KOREAN MEAL,
JAPANESE MEAL, YOU CAN SHOP, AND
EVERYONE IS INSULATED.
I'M GUILTY OF THIS, TOO, WHEN
YOU ARE HERE AMONG YOUR OWN
PEOPLE YOU LET DOWN YOUR GUARD.
SO WERE THERE SIGNS?
DID PEOPLE SEE SOMETHING?
DID THEY KNOW WHAT THEY WERE?
WE TALK ABOUT LOOKING FOR THE
SIGNS OF A MASS SHOOTER IN OUR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS DID ANYONE
SEE ANYTHING, KNOW HOW TO
COMMUNICATE IT TO THE POLICE?
WE WERE CHATTING IF YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW TO TALK TO THE POLICE,
THEY DON'T SPEAK YOUR LANGUAGE,
TALK TO YOUR KIDS.
>> ALL THE CITY LEADERS HERE,
INCLUDING THE SHERIFF, SAYING
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD FEEL SAFE
BECAUSE THE PERSON WHO COMMITTED
THIS IS NO LONGER WITH US BUT
THERE'S NO LONGER A SENSE OF
CELEBRATION THAT HAD JUST BEEN
IN PLACE HERE OVER THE WEEKEND.
THANK YOU BOTH.